>>Teacher: Go ahead, pull.
>>Narrator: From the outside, Mary
Scroggs Elementary School looks
like it could have been built
in the '20s, but this building,
part of a neo-traditional development
in Chapel Hill, North Carolina,
is just three years
old, and on the inside,
it's one of the most wired
schools in the country.
>>Teacher: And there's our web page,
and our end of the day summary.
>>Narrator: Here, tech
tools facilitate everything
from kindergarten web pages
to the daily morning newscast.
>>Student: The news is
brought to you by the students
from Miss Todd's third grade class.
Now, Bryson, what are
today's announcements?
>>Bryson: Hello Scroggs Frogs,
here are today's announcements.
Today, Wednesday, some people--
>>Susan: We let everyone
from kindergarteners to
fifth graders try it.
And then they practice with
their teachers in the classroom.
I give them a sample script,
they practice with that.
And then they come down, and that
morning, the five or ten kids
that are going to be on, and we run
through it a few times with them,
and then we do it live every day.
>>Student: I woke up, I listened
to all the different
sounds coming from--
>>Susan: I've got four
fifth grade helpers.
They're there every day to help
with all the backstage stuff,
and they basically
run the whole show.
>>Student: Dear Martin Luther
King, I have a problem.
It's that all children
cannot have equal access
to shelter and healthcare.
>>Susan: Sometimes it's really
good, sometimes it's not,
and sometimes we have
major calamities
and sometimes it goes smoothly.
>>Student: Today's date is
January 15th, 2000 and--
>>Narrator: The newscast is beamed
to every room in the building
over the school-wide data network.
>>Susan: The general setup of
technology here is that we have four
to five computers in every classroom,
and then we have three wireless labs
of iBook computers, so
everybody has a network account,
and a kid can walk just
about anywhere in the school,
log into the computer,
and get what they need.
All their documents
are available to them
from almost any computer
in the school.
>>Teacher: The laptop people,
Miss Dodge will come around
and let you know when it's
time for you to log in, okay?
All right.
>>Susan: And those wireless labs
come into play when a teacher needs
to introduce something new, or have
the whole class working on a project
at the same time, maybe to move
through a project a
little bit faster,
or because that's the best
way to teach the concept.
>>Teacher: The main thing that
I want you to focus on today,
is how to group your information
so when you start writing,
you'll be able to get
your paragraphs.
>>Susan: The inspiration,
and kidspiration,
are both very powerful tools,
because they allow children
to organize their thoughts and
their ideas before writing.
>>Teacher: A lot of people are
moving into their spreadsheets now.
Make sure you have the number of
shares of each stock filled out.
>>Narrator: Much of the
school's curriculum is delivered
through projects like this
stock picking competition.
>>Student: I get General Electric,
Walmart, Coca-Cola, Nike and Target.
>>Narrator: Students
often work in pairs,
with tech savvy students
tutoring their peers.
>>Student: Did you get your
stuff today or yesterday?
>>Student: Yesterday.
>>Susan: Kids who spend more
time on computers at home,
are much more comfortable doing
basic things here at school,
working the mouse, working the
keyboard, typing, scouting around,
being creative on the computer.
And we want to give kids who
don't have the resources at home,
necessarily, we want to give
them more opportunities.
>>Teacher: The goals of the
Tech at Home programs are
to extend the learning opportunities
and resources into students' homes--
>>Narrator: To help
bridge this digital divide,
the school established
a Tech at Home program,
which provides free computers and
low internet access fees to families
of students on free
and reduced lunch.
>>Julie: Our goal is that children
will be online every night,
they'll look up our website,
they'll-- when they see our website,
they'll see a homepage that will
give you updates of what's going
on at Mary Scroggs in our classroom.
They'll find a separate
homework link where they'll go
and see the homework for the week.
>>Student: Tuesday.
>>Dorothy: Tuesday, what
do you have to do today?
>>Narrator: So far, the Tech at
Home program is getting high marks
from teachers and parents
like Dorothy Setliff.
>>Dorothy: They're naturally inclined
to start using computers early,
they play games on it, and
it's so that it becomes,
homework becomes like
part of the game.
Having him start now, means that
it will be so much easier later on.
>>How do you spell
music, do you remember?
>>Student: U, U, U..
>>Dorothy: That's right, then what?
>>Julie: A majority of the homework
that we're moving more toward is,
they respond through the e-mail to
me, because it's a really great way
to keep track of their homework,
I can reply very easily.
Less paperwork, I don't
have a stack of papers to go
through that sometimes
don't make it back home.
It's just much easier to
give them immediate feedback
through the e-mail.
>>Student: Send it
to me on the e-mail.
>>Dorothy: And having a nice way of
getting in contact with the teacher,
just send an e-mail, and you get
an e-mail back, rather than trying
to catch a teacher on the telephone.
Now old technology,
this is much better.
>>Kathleen: That's the
sound a crow makes,
let's see if we hear that sound?
>>Narrator: In addition
to new technology,
Mary Scroggs new building
design facilitates a variety
of learning experiences.
>>Kathleen: Put your
binoculars on, I see something
on that tree right there.
Can you look right straight--
>>I think that the building
itself is just wonderful.
It's beautiful and
I love the porches.
The area for science, for what
we're doing with the birds,
as far as having bird feeders out
there, and the children being able
to go out and watch the birds.
>>Kathleen: You see a blue jay?
>>Student: Me, too.
>>Narrator: Inside, every
classroom features wall coverings
that allow children's work
to be displayed everywhere.
There are several rooms
where teachers can gather
and small nooks for
one-on-one sessions.
In fact, the building
has been an asset
in recruiting prospective
teachers, especially when they learn
that they will have their
own office and phone.
>>Paula: I think typically,
over the years,
teachers have gotten
by on a shoestring.
They're told they're professionals,
but sometimes not always
treated as professionals.
For teachers, it's a
big deal to have a phone
that they can use throughout the day,
either to communicate with parents,
or to be available to
their own families.
>>Narrator: The physical
plant is just part
of the appeal of working here.
For kindergarten teacher, Kathleen
Eveleigh, the best of Mary Scroggs,
the technology, the literacy focus,
and the parent involvement parts,
come together every day when her kids
write the end of the day summary.
>>Kathleen: Who has something to
tell me about what we've done today?
Jeffrey?
>>Jeffrey: Are we going
to have enough room
for the whole webpage
just on that one line?
>>Kathleen: We will,
you'll be surprised.
It just goes right down.
>>When we started discussing ways
to make the webpage more powerful,
the suggestion came up of
putting a daily synopsis
of what we had done during the
day, and it was very easy to sit
down with the children,
just put the keyboard
in my lap, and just go to it.
>>Student: Some people
want to reading books.
>>Kathleen: Some people--
>>And it tied in with
what we do in literacy,
which is to have children say things
and you write them out for them,
and then they're able to
read what they have said.
And so it tied into the balanced
literacy that we do in our school.
>>Our mystery was four o'clock.
Very good.
>>All of a sudden, I was
getting e-mails from parents,
letters from parents, I love the
website, it's helping me so much,
I can get things from the web page,
and then ask my child about it,
and we have so much to talk about,
so that kind of input
just got me more excited,
and then I just started
doing it more and more,
and making sure I was
doing it every day.
>>Jeffrey: We had a
fantastic super day.
>>Kathleen: We had a
Wow, that sounds so great.
You guys did a good job.
See you-- do you want me
to put, see you tomorrow?
See you tomorrow.
>>Narrator: For more information on,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.